Marvel movies aren't always totally
accurate to the comics they adapt and
lots can change between the page and the
big screen unfortunately this means that
some characters end up having some of
their best powers removed here are the
Marvel movie characters with powers you
didn't know about while he's a
formidable hero in the MCU Falcon
actually doesn't have any bonafide
superpowers to speak of in the comics
however Sam Wilson has a much greater
range of abilities Captain America Civil
War introduces Red Wing a flying drone
that Falcon uses against crossbones
terrorists and later in the fight
against the pro Accords heroes in the
comics however Red Wing is an actual
Hawk with whom Sam Wilson shares a
telepathic bond without saying a word
Sam can communicate with Red Wing give
him commands and see through his eyes
not only does Wilson have powers but for
a time the Falcon believes he's actually
a mutant too
the reveal comes in the 1983 through
1984 Falcon miniseries when Wilson
becomes a target of the mutant hunting
Sentinel robots this was revised however
before Falcon could join NEX teams in
2003 Avengers number 64 it's revealed
that while Falcon isn't a mutant he's
still more powerful than ever
initially believing his telepathic bond
only worked between himself and Red Wing
Falcon learns his abilities can work on
any bird as well as whole flocks of
birds simultaneously both the comics and
the film's depict an Incredible Hulk
who's tough to kill but in 2018 the job
of hoaxes enemies got that much tougher
in Avengers number 684 the Hulk is
brought back from the dead having been
put in the ground two years previous by
Hawkeye in Civil War 2 number 3 as part
of the story of his resurrection it's
revealed the Hulk can't be killed at
least not for good reaching far back
into comics of the past the writers
showed multiple times that the Hulk died
only to soon return often with little or
no explanation the story then leads
directly into the series immortal Hulk
in which both Bruce Banner and his alter
ego are repeatedly killed often more
than once in the same issue only to
return within a few hours ironically a
little bit of this has been reflected in
the films but it was actually before the
Hulk's immortal status was established
in the comics in the final battle of
Seventeen's thor ragnarok banner leaps
from the grandmaster spaceship onto the
Bifrost
apparently expecting to transform into
the Hulk before he lands hey it happened
before
instead banner hits the Rainbow Bridge
head-on and it looks like he might
genuinely be dead until moments later
when the Hulk emerges Eddie Brock and
his alien symbiote showed no shortage of
strength in 2018 s venom but in the
comics his list of powers is even longer
for one venom has the ability to mimic
the super powers of any enhanced humans
he bonds with which is why in the comics
long after the symbiote separated from
Peter Parker venom still uses
spider-man's abilities while bonded with
the symbiote Eddie can make himself
appear to be wearing any clothing he
chooses and can even disguise himself as
other people and while venom shows that
the symbiote can heal its human host
when Flash Thompson takes on the
symbiote in the comics it proves able to
do something even more extraordinary
Thompson lost his legs as the result of
wounds he suffered during the Iroquois
but after Thompson bonds with venom the
symbiote grows legs whenever Thompson
uses its powers giving the veteran a
chance to walk whenever he wishes in
Avengers age of Ultron the MC use
version of The Scarlet Witch uses a
range of powers such as telekinesis and
telepathy which only seem to get
stronger as the franchise progresses but
in the comics scarlet witch's abilities
are even more complex and staggeringly
powerful - there's nothing more
and a miracle
in the source material Wanda uses chaos
magic to warp reality on a smaller scale
she might do something like causing
metal to rust so she can break through a
solid wall or if she was threatened by a
crowd of enemies she could release a
blast of magical energy to take them all
down without ever breaking a sweat but
on a larger scale scarlet witch's powers
can have literally world-changing
consequences on multiple occasions for
example she has brought the dead back to
life in the 2004 event Avengers
disassembled she generates whole armies
of enemies like Ultron robots and Kree
warriors to attack the Avengers in the
following years house of M she changes
the face of the world including making
her fellow mutants the dominant world
power then towards the end of the event
she takes away every mutants powers by
infamously stating no more mutants only
the intervention of a certain sorcerer
supreme allows a handful of mutants to
retain their powers in the Incredible
Hulk Bruce Banner and Betty Ross go to
scientist Samuel Sterns for help in
finding a cure for banners condition
after Banner is captured by the military
Emil Blonsky forces Sterne's to inject
him with banners blood turning him into
the abomination the last time Stern's
appears the abomination knocks him to
the ground and banners blood begins
dripping into an open wound on the
scientists head causing his skin to
start bubbling so what's all that about
well in the comics Samuel Sterns is the
hoax arch-nemesis the leader when he
first appears in the comics he's the
polar opposite of banner rather than a
brainy scientist turned into a
super-strong monster by gamma rays he's
a high school dropout made highly
intelligent by the same radiation as
well as taking on a radically different
appearance the leader enjoys beyond
genius intelligence and a host of
psychic powers
he's been shown to use telekinesis and
can also take over people's minds and
have them do his bidding the only
limitation to his mental control over
others is that it doesn't work on people
affected by gamma radiation such as the
Hulk himself one of the few actors from
The Incredible Hulk to have made a
return later in the MCU is William Hertz
Thaddeus Ross Thunderbolt is one of the
hoax oldest enemies and in the comics he
eventually becomes a little more than
just the Secretary of State in 2008 Hulk
number one a new red skinned Hulk shows
up to
havock and it looks like he's even more
powerful than the original its
eventually revealed that this monster is
the general himself as it turns out Ross
got the powers from a group calling
itself the Intelligencia composed of
brainy Marvel villains like MODOK the
red ghost and the mad thinker Red Hulk
has abilities comparable to that of the
original but with one major difference
he can absorb energy to keep making
himself stronger and stronger this added
advantage makes him capable of beating
the heck out of the original halt
Iron Man and Thor among others after
being defeated by the original Hulk the
red hope becomes something of a hero and
he soon welcomed into the ranks of the
Avengers after the events of the 2012
line wide event Avengers vs. x-men Ross
forms his own version of the
Thunderbolts as a means of fighting
injustice without the legal and moral
constraints of the Avengers which would
be a pretty ironic turn up for the MCU
version of the character in her earliest
comic book appearances Betty Ross is
little more than Bruce banners love
interest and usually takes on the role
of damsel in distress but her role in
the Hulk's life has led to a number of
transformations for Betty some of which
have made her physically powerful enough
to handle the green Goliath one-on-one
in 1973's Incredible Hulk numbers 168
and 169 Betty is brainwashed by the
villain MODOK and transformed into the
harpy a gamma-irradiated flying creature
with claws super-strength and the
ability to fire energy blasts from her
hands while her tenure as the avian
monster is brief she proves powerful
enough to ko the Hulk twice in that time
for a much longer stretch Betty takes on
the role of red she-hulk this goes down
when MODOK and the leader revived her
from death and give her similar powers
to Red Hulk as red she-hulk Betty is
brainwashed and largely portrayed as a
villain eventually however she strikes
out on her own as a hero briefly joins
the defenders and even teams up with the
original Hulk best of both worlds while
Betty's red she-hulk powers are forcibly
stripped away from her in 2014 s Hulk
number 8 in later comics she proves even
more powerful in 2019 immortal Hulk
number 14
Betty is shot in the head and killed by
the mercenary Bushwhacker she returns in
later issues as the monstrous red harpy
with a form similar to that she took on
as the
the only red instead of green and that
definitely didn't happen in the movie
the movie version of beast has a lot in
common with his comic counterpart one
aspect of Hank McCoy that isn't depicted
in the films however is his tendency to
dramatically change his physical
appearance sometimes these changes are
explained by plot and other times
they're explained simply by the
character undergoing a secondary
mutation when he first appears in 1963 s
uncanny x-men number one the Beast
doesn't look particularly different from
other humans later Hank drinks a serum
that makes him more powerful and covers
his body in gray fur after a clash with
the villainous Quasimodo in 1972 s
Amazing Adventures number 14 beasts gray
fur turns blue leading to the classic
bouncing blue beast look most fans are
familiar with he remains in this form
for many years with a brief break during
x-factor when he's temporarily made to
look more human when Beast becomes a
regular in Grant Morrison's
game-changing new x-men premiering in
2001 McCoy is still covered with blue
fur but his features take on a more
feline appearance as a result of that
secondary mutation the change makes
McCoy fear he's losing his grip on
humanity and he actually considers
looking into a cure for his mutant gene
in astonishing x-men in all-new x-men
premiering in the early 2010's beast
undergoes yet another secondary mutation
it frees him from the feline form giving
him a bulkier look less hair on his head
and a face that looks a little like a
bats the MCU Drax definitely isn't a guy
you'd want to mess with
[Music]
this version of the character is mostly
inspired by the 2005 Drax the destroyer
miniseries in which the titular hero is
killed and subsequently resurrected in a
less powerful but more intelligent form
but there is an older version of the
hero and this one is far stronger
unlike the version depicted in the
movies the Drax of the comics is
specifically created to destroy Thanos
by Chronos the mad Titans grandfather in
this iteration Drax could fly and fire
powerful energy blasts out of his hands
while Drax rarely seems quite up to the
task of defeating Thanos he holds his
own against him
which is pretty impressive in of itself
after being resurrected just before 1991
s Infinity Gauntlet event Drax is more
powerful than ever though he's afflicted
by diminished intelligence still he
proves himself the physical equal of
Marvel's most powerful heroes including
the Hulk Thor and the Silver Surfer Drax
also seems to have the built-in capacity
to revive himself after death though he
usually changes significantly after a
resurrection there's never any real
explanation as to why he keeps coming
back to life again and again other than
his quest to kill thanos presumably as
long as Stannis is alive Drax will never
be able to stay dead check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]